foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody
let's go
yeah get in there sweater
that's right hell yeah brother we're
riding with
our good old boy ladies and gentlemen
John Brown domestic terrorists yeah it's
just not showing up which John Brown
technically was
John Brown was a good old boy John Brown
is uh I guess America's first official
domestic terrorist oh fantastic yeah
they're one good company but like but
like basically not in the same way that
like these guys in the Republican Party
are but uh you know like
he he basically proves the whole
sentiment behind
uh one man's terrorist is another man's
freedom fighter
oh really that's what he did yeah fought
for freedom you want to read my mug says
[__] cab
I see that oh it does I didn't know that
why what's going on is there anything
new in the the lawsuits no I just remind
everyone that he's a piece of [__] time
and time that's cool
thank you we were talking about John
Brown I don't think I ever learned about
him in school I learned a lot about the
Civil War and early America and all that
but I don't think
John Brown was a little too early to the
cause I think that's what happened
that's why they hanged him for trees
ahead of his time he was like Annie
he would walk into a town uh with a
Sarsaparilla and a tumbleweed
come right before him he looked over the
saloon said
any slave was here
anybody here on any slaves yeah I mean
he was he was dog [__] at he was dog
[__] at like uh the leather business
like he tried to do you have like a
leathery like all of his business
ventures failed really constantly but he
was very my man was very good at
liberating uh enslaved African Folk
he's good you'd love to see one final
this of course is uh Hassan's Merc which
is kind of fire I like the whole thing
of you know reclaiming our hunting Roots
as as liberals yeah the way I see it is
like I mean for me it was like about uh
what I love and what I love about
American culture what American culture
means to me
and um I think there's a lot of good in
the in the South as well that oftentimes
gets overlooked a lot or like like
Southern Heritage I guess that
oftentimes gets overlooked uh and in
American culture and I think like you
can be ye as [__] and still uh promote
good values
I never said you couldn't man the only
thing I value is how [__] big this
pumpkin get around the time that the
festival come around man you ever seen a
pumpkin this big well I got me a blue
ribbon last year all right
I can't speak on the pumpkins
but what I can't speak what do you grow
squash what kind of vegetables you be
growing for the Harvest celebration boy
you know my friend uh well my best
friend will uh he his family has like a
like a barn yeah you make that
distinction I mean he's yeah anyway why
are you getting caught up on all the
best friend I thought that that was
interesting it's like an irrelevant
detail anyway it's not you want you
clarified you said my friend no my best
friend okay well you you made an aside
to clarify that well he wasn't just like
a friend friend you know I mean I wanted
to I wanted to like uh let it be known
anyway that's sweet
um special he he participates in the
Michigan Barn restoration competition
and I think he won
yeah did you know that they have like
they literally have a Michigan
yeah
they have a Michigan Barn preservation
Network and I believe he won 2023 Barn
of the year
that's a fine Bond there brother
yeah it is I can see it right now ebers
Family Barn that's it that's that's his
as his family born brat there my brother
that's a fine Barn boy that's some
that's some straight like you know
Middle America [__] right there just
like a barn competition well you could
comfortably fit at least five catsuities
not their Barn brother
I don't even know what you're saying you
are such a bicose to live it's not even
fun bro I'm tweaking their language dude
I don't care you might be friends with
the barn Builder but you ain't no Barn
you're gonna say this is that's how we
talk in Michigan
I'm not talking about Michigan boy I'm
talking about them good old boys
I'm talking about the good South
Brothers
hey you [__] gave me this merch bro I
didn't realize this is what was gonna
happen
I brought this out of me I know no the
attitude comes uh you know the attitude
is on your own what you make of it y'all
you ever met a two before
come on meet me a Jew down at the
carnival have a meet a Jew Booth down at
the uh Festival of this year
are there a lot of are there actually
there's not a lot of Jewish people in uh
in the South when I went to college
there's a lot of people I met who were
outside of the state
were like I have never met a Jew before
in my life
I had friends from abroad one was
Spanish
she lived in a
Barcelona she says I'm and she was like
25. because I'm the first Jewish person
she's ever met
wait
you're talking about someone from
Barcelona though yeah but still well
yeah the Spanish did famously do some
stuff I want to surprise me it just did
you know you know who uh brought the the
Jews in though when the when the
Spaniards yes sir it was John Brown no
it was the Ottoman Empire as a matter of
fact yeah
there you go thank you brother
thank you brother that's Auschwitz but
yeah that's why that's why she had never
met a Jewish person I think well that's
true and that's why we gonna do here
dude out of Booth down here at the
carnival this year
25 cents come say hello to a bona fide
Jude that's right
come here Macon and all that kind of fun
little stuff man you got the twirl the
curl hair come on now let's just say hi
now brother
mm-hmm he knew it was called a yamaka
that was actually a very Cosmopolitan of
this character yeah one of them Julie
old hats there they were but
they wear like a little pancake on their
head
that's more like it yeah well we got a
fun show here
I mean we're already having fun aren't
we
oh yeah by the way full send we were
talking about how they went to Israel
we're going to watch it on Friday
but they're selling fulse and yamakas
your thoughts they're [__] fully
sending it dude wait they sold out of
this [__] brother they sold out yeah
this is gonna be the most annoying
little kids that [__] get this at
like at the synagogue you're gonna
you're gonna see like you can identify
all the annoying little shits it's just
ungodly with their [__] full send hat
oh my God it's almost like it's like
having a PornHub yamaka it's like
that the [__] a holy place no bro you
don't understand on God I did I I would
totally wear that to shul I'm not even
joking aside it gives a little flavor
you are already they've got a good
flavor bro it's all different flavors
flavors you don't want to put them out
and that's that's full send is that I
think hahaha
why are you looking through their
merchandise Ethan what the [__] I'm just
curious once I saw the yamako sold out I
was like what the [__] going on over
here yeah because they have other kind
of Israel themed [__] that sold out it
says shalom
senders oh
Shalom Sanders [__] Sunday let's go
let's go over to the border and send it
on over to some Palestinians yeah oh
Jesus okay all right no shotties or
anything no shotties lots of shoddies
down here
smoking gar is dead can you put on
AstroWorld
um yeah
so um congratulations to song one best
streamer
that's a big category you know
yeah we had a we had stiff competition
we had tough competition pay money wubby
was on there
um they did not use the best photo of me
on that you look kind of big eddish here
yeah I was like because I was
I I it goes hard thank you yeah thank
you that was uh Dolce Gabbana made us
wear that because I was doing the red
carpet and they were like sponsoring the
event kind of Dolce Gabbana that's a
nice close yeah I bought some other
clothes that I wanted to wear on the red
carpet they were like they had this this
Italian man coming he's like Francisco
he's like no I have this clothing for
you but he did you he did you good man
everybody I think so too yeah off the
rack and everything oh he's gonna wear
like a [__] Gucci Hawaiian shirt or
something before Oh got him
uh no I wanted to wear some Japanese
[__] like I want I'm on my Steven Seagal
but
um but basically uh I was just excited
the prospect to be able to fit into
clothing that is just like right off the
shelf so I I uh put it on it worked I
wore it Dolce Gabbana apparently wanted
to get it back after and like no I don't
understand that I know that bit designer
clothing they do that they send it out
to people and then they ask for it back
it's like what the [__] it's like no
what are you gonna do once I fart in it
it's mine okay there's no like what do
you mean people have it that's good [__]
yeah I still have it apparently
apparently a couple of the other people
that did the Red Carpet like they left
it in their hotel rooms for Dolce to
pick it up and I was like you guys are
stupid I told you not to do that well
it's always better if this is the I mean
so this is probably like a that whole
outfit might be like a couple Grand no
way more Dolce gabbana's like high
luxury probably like Max 10 grand no
more you think more than 10 grand I
think so no shots
whoa what the [__]
Martini tux Yeah it's you're so wrong
and Neiman Marcus it's
the the oh no it's a solid suit never
mind that's not the type okay
um this suit is like three grand two
grand two thousand the jacket or the
whole suit
well just a regular Blazer is two
thousand three hundred dollars okay so
you're right oh yeah that's four grand
it's uh the the fit tuxedo suit just for
the suit is four grand yeah yeah that's
why I said ten but then you've got yeah
ten Grands probably that's probably
that's why I said like Max 10. it's like
the Gucci is like six yeah you're
probably right it's so expensive well
hey 10 grand on the come up boys let's
go I mean yeah I'll be that [__] brother
I was not I was not [__] giving that
back to that hell no [__] no
good for you man came up big that night
so congrats did you how did that feel to
win that award was it nice
um be honored I mean I
it felt great winning the award I mean I
I went up against your rage gaming who
who has also had a really really awesome
year I really thought he was gonna win
your rage gaming uh he's uh
I guess he's like kind of an
up-and-coming content creator he only
recently did a face reveal basically you
thought he'd win yeah yeah he's he's
popping he's got like 20K average uh
concurrence I get more than that where's
my [__] nominee well you're right
actually they don't have like anything
for podcasts and stuff
um but regardless it's more so like
twitch Focus but like there's definitely
YouTubers involved as well
but uh it's mostly about streaming and
um so you won just chatting yeah you say
I do on my podcast you you chat for sure
yeah you're you're a chatter that is
right but I think you would probably
categorized as like a live podcast or
something it's probably a little
different just chatting is a is a
category on Twitch
it's a category that I use the most just
same sure yeah me too I use that
category who else was nominated
uh it was iron Mouse who is uh V uh is a
v tuber for V Shoujo okay she's dope
she's awesome
um pay money wubby yeah you said that
and your Rich gave me it was just us oh
just you three yeah it's an xqc just
chatter or he doesn't get that no he he
won variety variety implies that you
play like a variety of video games and
you're just chatting as well yeah they
put me in just chatting and put a mix
you see in variety they kind of queued
you up to win that one I'll be honest
because I never heard of any of those
people
well I think it was tough it was tough
competition it was definitely you don't
watch Twitch too no I don't know you do
well they really picked up a real
flattering picture of baby money I mean
I guess that's his logo
that is good that's good yeah
what did you think love were you
surprised that son took it down no of
course not of course not clearly I was I
was surprised but um as soon as I won I
also knew oh here comes the [__] you
know wave of [__] on Twitter well
anytime I have fun got forbid I'm like
yeah uh oh I'm having too much fun can't
wait for like every [__] Psychopathic
individual to be like oh he's having fun
time to bring that down funny you say
that
because one of my favorite people on the
internet Dark Viper 14 pages oh no you
remember this guy bro you just met about
14.
pages
I [__] on this guy in the whole series
of videos when you when you mention him
this is why he does it so that he can
get a mention and he's just like I just
wish him well bro I I don't think he's
like doing all right on page 14 well he
wrote 14 pages which he's clearly bro he
said he's very focused he said reaction
like reacting to YouTube videos is akin
to rape
he's not wrong
wrote Proud at the comments under this
post oh he's he's encouraging people to
[__] hate yeah he was like I'm so first
of all what bro look look look let's say
we have disagreements right I'm on my
I'm on my PR Arc I'm trying to be like
even keeled I'm trying to be a better
person I'm trying to be a nicer person
let's say we have a difference in
opinion on like reactions right
like obviously I think maybe Dark Viper
it goes a little too him on the react
stuff uh he he considers it to be like
the most unethical thing you can do
we have a disagreement right we have a
we have a reasonable disagreement on
that issue
I'm so proud of the comments under this
post like everyone's [__] on this
guy I love that I'm so happy like dude
you're just demonstrating how unhappy
you are in general yeah I think Dark
Viper may think you are the Bill Cosby
of YouTube If you give some hope when
people recognize that a guy sitting in a
mansion hosting watch parties or other
people's hard work shouldn't bring forth
Awards 99 of the work done by others 100
of the money into Hassan's bank account
socialist by the way he says okay I
don't have time for that but okay if you
want me to consider your thesis I need
another 14 pages
his meticulously crafted 14-page
manifestos
meticulously argued I wanted the
original species up in this [__]
I'm trying to be nicer towards my
interlocutors uh in this in this year so
I'm not gonna say something nice about
Viper I I don't know anything about him
I've never watched any
[Music]
well no one thing I know about him is
that he's very do it he's very um
how do I say
Scholastic the man wrote 14-page essay
yeah look the thing is every time we
talk about this he he will he'll make
like multiple videos because I think it
like you know we all have we all have an
audience of haters as well and you know
people like to get in on that a little
bit maybe boost your Revenue a little
bit
it's diminishing returns and it also
doesn't uh it doesn't help your mental
space you know but the one thing I'll
say is
um even if we have a disagreement on
this matter the overwhelming majority if
not every single person I react to
content-wise
uh on my stream are our friends of mine
or other content creators who who you
know very much you can react to [__]
it's called fair use it's a whole
Doctrine in the United States I know you
live in Australia where Free Speech
isn't a thing but welcome to America
[__] regards an American company twitch
customers American company Amazon guess
what's American company these nuts [__]
regardless
um
hold on Hassan because I know you're
being nice I'm about to John Brown up in
this [__] I don't know you what I John
Brown for any Fair my point is my point
is that like I mean here's another
example is meet King came up to me he
was at the award show me Canyon yeah
great guy yeah and I'd never met him
before but I've watched his videos on
stream before and he came up and he was
like hey man thanks a lot for watching
the videos like it really helps a lot
like you you have uh you've you've
helped me uh grow on Twitch
you know what I mean of course
like I personally when I when I was
coming up I loved when people watched my
content yeah why don't you just dark
white whatever dude it's just like it's
an odd dynamic because like it makes it
the only most of the time the people
that actually get on board with that are
Watchers like audience members who don't
make content themselves and it's rarely
ever like content creators especially
big content creators or even smaller
content creators who uh find it to be
like a bad thing but we will never be
able to have this conversation because
they immediately hit the paid and
exposure Button as though it's like uh
as though there's any sort of like
remuneration uh necessary in this
circumstance
um but you know I I try to be as nice
about it as possible
but uh people still think that he does
not connect I play videos and I walk
away that's what the that's what the
matter is I have seen you go to the
bathroom while you play a video I have
yeah I have I have peed yeah but on
average I think it takes uh one minute
and 26 seconds to pee yeah people climb
my pisses that's yeah it's pretty weird
yeah I guess maybe it's not that long I
haven't timed it but I'd be curious you
gotta account for walking time well your
bathroom's pretty close yeah the one
here is a little bit far yeah so one
minute six seconds for the for the
pissing
um so yeah I do I do that and sometimes
I I heat my chicken on the microwave or
I pick up my ubereats yeah yeah yeah so
that that also takes one minute I think
total well congratulations Hassan on
just chatting Dark Viper [__]
eat my dirty [__] [__] I
I'd like look I just wish him well I
hope here I got 14 turds you can eat
[__] I hope
you know what I mean is in all sincerity
I hope that you know Dark Viper is doing
well and I hope he's uh you know living
a happy healthy life you're sliding him
he sees that as a slight you know I'm
not bad I'm not no I know what you're
the man is unwell he's like manic as
[__] the dude is like so jacked up on
some kind of drugs is but it is I've
never seen pupils that were about to
explode somebody's I don't I don't know
about any of that [__] I just think that
like when you see that I'm trying to be
as reasonable it's like a little Cherry
Bomb say something along the lines of
like I'm so happy people are [__] on
this guy in a moment where like some of
the industry is like recognizing him or
whatever like that doesn't seem like a
very that's not something a very happy
person would say like celebrating
uh I've probably said something like
that yeah but you're not a very happy
person so yeah my point exactly I don't
think I'm happy I've done that [__] too
in my least happy moments so that's what
I'm talking about
you know
um you know you can be a hater he's just
dumb bro you just you're he's just a
[__] idiot bro he's 14 pages
all right let's move on who cares talked
about him too much yeah react content uh
that like react gate meta doesn't bang
in the same way that like some of these
guys wanted to bang mostly because like
all art is derivative
everyone pretty much does it and most
content creators like almost all content
creators with the exception of a couple
people that no one's really reacting to
uh they they appreciate it they
appreciate the Boost that comes from it
too
nobody cares but him dude he just butt
hurt nobody watches [__] let's move on
uh dark of Viper thank you for the
accolades so you said last week Michael
Knowles looked I had a cartoon smile
that's such a good girl somebody nailed
it although I have to say this
Ratatouille guy or whoever the [__] he
is is way more handsome like I would
[__] this mouse Michael Knowles would
make what he's hot he's kind of have you
seen Michael knows his gay sex scene
all right uh you guys have not seen
Michael Knowles gay sex
uh uh I've had dreams like that but I
haven't physically seen it
uh there's this it's safe for work uh I
think but well let's pretty sure pretty
sure Michael I mean it's gonna be weird
to Google so it's not going to come up I
found it but
oh wow let me see it okay so am I just
recording it off of a laptop let me see
if I can find a better uh Source because
well tell me about it as we pull it up
um if I'm not mistaken I'm not entirely
certain I didn't watch it uh because I'm
not good that's right um no I I
uh I I saw a tweet about it but
apparently I mean Michael knows the
failed actor he wanted to he wanted to
make it big in Hollywood didn't work so
of course what did he do Apple form a
right wing uh political commentator
uh who's spewing hate
he did a gay scene and apparently he did
a gay scene in in one of his like uh
movies or whatever he was just crazy
what it looks like he's like the most
hateful homophobic bigot of all time not
as bad as Matt oh it's just a it's a
student though I mean he's the one that
called for a genocide of trans people
yeah he did and he's still doing it too
okay so here's Michael Knowles
oh man he looks like Nathan Fielder have
gone wrong
gonna bomb
this is awesome man I'm already loving
this
give him a kiss bro afraid to go inside
that
I can leave
give him a kiss brother
yeah what is that [__] whoa
and there it is
that was go ahead
wow he's right thanks have you not done
it with me if we don't get into that
it's so bad
that's not a lot is it
listen
all right good listen I'm very tempting
at lgbtq I love him God damn it I love
them
that's I never done anything that gay in
my life
I mean yeah you're that was that was
pretty gay Ethan that was that he was
you know having gay sex simulating
having gay sex because this guy actually
he talked he spends a major like
probably the majority of his day talking
about how people or LGBT you're wrong
wow that's Michael knows all right
everybody so that's the the question I
have is like a lot of these guys they'll
say like if you see gay stuff in TV
shows and and whatnot like you'll become
gay so what if you do the gay stuff in
the TV show then that ain't gay is that
like is that even worse like how does
that work like you are the guy who's
like making people gay shouts out to
Michael knows exactly he's so dog
[__] acting I don't think you could
turn anyone gay with that yeah it's
unfortunate I think they cut out the
good part that was yeah that was weird
that was mid we gotta
that was for sure acting level Sean Cody
logo on that though
who's that it's a famous I think it's
like gay PornHub John Cody yeah he's a
gay guy I don't know if it's like one
guy I think it's like uh it's like a hub
he has his own game yeah amateur gay sex
films check out sexy twinks and amateur
jokes I just Google it on your laptop
what's his what's the name heard you so
Michael at home his home can remember
what's the name of the site Sean Cody
John Cody yeah it's like write that down
all right somebody submitted this is
pretty good they called this leftovers
in a nutshell Hassan tell me what you
think if you're
for free food true and toys and toys
okay like that
but freaking there's one thing that you
need to know about your idea I've seen
I've seen this country I've seen I've
heard I've heard about politics I don't
care about politics bruh
laughs
I love that that's how you're supposed
to react when someone says I gotta bring
the taxes down that's so awesome I don't
care about that those kids are freaking
cool as hell
also just kind of top of the new stuff
and then we're getting to the good stuff
here Hassan I want to also congratulate
you it was a big week for you also ratio
uh President Biden oh yeah I'm the
president now yep that's how that works
that's how that works president Brandon
R.I.P Bozo you're done son give me the
[__] white house right now
well for good cause uh Biden was wishing
of course
McConnell who fell down the stairs like
Nana
uh but didn't [__] die Ethan he did
not die yeah he made it yeah he made it
he made it gravity bro gravity has I
thought gravity was way stronger you
know think about it think about all the
all the times of gravity has like failed
to do the job Governor Greg Abbott with
the tree you know what I mean
uh Mitch McConnell
it's [__] up I wish this in response
Daryl Ford in the stairs I hit him with
the buy dog which I don't know what that
even is
that's an ancient scream from uh old
people Facebook oh someone was like I'm
not doing well I'm a hot cancer and I'm
dying and whatever all just the worst
Doom and Gloom and then um
her like Bingo partner who's also 80 or
something just hit her with this Emoji I
love that okay that's deep lore I didn't
even know what that was about yeah
um but yeah I I uh I tweeted about it
how about how [__] ridiculous it is
you know he just spent his entire
awful life like denying Americans health
care but he gets to like get the
Platinum Senate health care that's
taxpayer funding yeah that's sad like
suck my dick dude [__] [__]
probably happy you fell down the stairs
like [__] I'll get this [__] put my feet
up get me some of them
opiates I hear all kinds about it was
funny though because like all of the
trumpers hate him too so the timeline
was full of like uh you know irony
poison left this being like Oh R.I.P
Bozo [__] die and also the Maga
supporters that are like real Patriot
mom 1488 was like Mitch McConnell's
gonna die and I'm excited like let's
celebrate that sort of thing it was
awesome good well wishes for our yeah
United America for like a brief moment
leader yeah but actually speaking of
prominent
um conservatives Rudy Giuliani of course
who is who was New York's mayor actually
America's marriable America's mayor
America's mayor post 911 and um he was
Trump's attorney as you guys all
remember so well Giuliani he nasty
filthy sloppy disgusting filthy [__]
animal yeah so he has his own podcast
have you seen this
uh I have not okay you're gonna love
this so this from I think just yesterday
this is fresh off the press so here's
the kind of quality Uh current event
coverage you could expect from you Rudy
Giuliani because they somebody asked me
about something called
Oscar
what Oscar oh the Oscars oh it's they're
uh oh it's a family
some big thing happened last night that
I am called Oscar it's called the Oscars
it's an award show and I watched big
to-do in Hollywood last night last night
I I watched chosen which I recommend to
everyone to watch before Easter
so there that is huh
pretty stunning stuff there by Rudy
Giuliana I think I think there's some I
mean he's like he's gone yeah this is
dementia bro he looks like the Crypt
Keeper there's no way he's not know what
the Oscars is that's just the boomero
Oscar Oscar oh family oh yeah like the
Adam family yeah the Oscars oh like
yeah sex oh my God Rudy Giuliani was on
top when he did drag okay he's doing
very well that's it that was that was
when he was goaded peaked
you think he could be the faking
dementia to avoid jail time that is
interesting I don't think he's that
slick no no no no no he's not it's wild
that this man like it was only two years
ago that this man was the president of
the United States personal lawyer and
was like trying to outside of a dildo
shop two and two years later yeah the
Oscars what uh here is Hassan after
ratioing the president yeah no that's my
I'm the president now yeah that's how
this works back off yeah the Oval Office
has never looked what's up guys live on
the live from Washington D.C
fantastic evening here
[Music]
what would the first thing be if you
would do if UB became president on
stream
what would be the first thing executive
action dude oh my God I bring in I bring
in like all the all the bankers yeah and
all the healthcare okay hold on into the
[__] white house I bring them into
the White House hold on okay and I just
make him sit down and
um I would just have I would have a
wonderful fireside chat with you'd go
John Brown on them no I would not I
would never do that I would just
televise
I would televise uh you know a a fun
wonderful Firestone Jesus you would do
it like an Isis like National [__]
exit no I would just you're the only one
saying execution yeah I'm not saying
that at all I would just say like it
sounds like you're gonna get out the
Gallows the American people uh have have
decided that uh you know you're you're
morally uh bankrupt industry
specifically Healthcare especially like
is is no longer going to be a Private
for-profit Industry we've decided to
nationalize it and you do that with
executive action no but it doesn't
matter you're just stealing power yeah I
would just like I would be a tyrant you
were it buzzled your way yeah I just I I
ratioed my way into the [__]
presidency and then you know now I'm the
commander right yeah I would bring them
you know military style line them up and
and be like do you guys have any
dissenting opinions on the matter you
know what I mean I would like to hear
them out right and then I'd be like
sorry it's illegal to to say no to the
president and then I would uh whatever
the criminal punishment is I guess it
sounds like a really utopian world
it would be objectively better than the
current predicament that we're in not
for them yeah no well okay well you got
to look at it from a utilitarian yeah
yeah you know what I mean some people
are gonna suffer a little bit yeah I got
you I got you okay well that's exciting
um hey meatball Ron you guys know Ron
DeSantis governor of Florida who's given
Trump run for his money well he is
actually um oh my God I did not see this
what the [__] is this what the [__] oh
no this so Fox News loves rayanda
Sanchez they're trying to build him up
and uh this their reporter I don't know
how to say his last name Brian
so here is good old boy around the
Father and Son mm-hmm it's time to run
for president would you think it's
sometime it's safe to say that that
would be one of your goals I would I
would only I would only first of all I
have to comment on how absurd this
premise is like y'all are two grown men
playing catch like who's daddy right now
like what what the [__] is this this is
so sad why did they choose to do this
they're good old boys
that's crazy this is like the weirdest
[__] I've ever that's all this is
awesome wow Murdoch has fallen off dude
there's a rationale for me to accomplish
things on behalf of the people we're
playing catch wrong throw the ball about
whether I could serve or not serve in a
variety of capacities but I'll tell you
you know the as governor and if you're a
determined executive you know you can
make things happen and we've done that
in Florida what can we expect the big
announcement depends how good we do in
this legislative session
oh my God
his throat's not that bad he he is such
a Charisma suck dude he he's he doesn't
have it I think comments on his throw by
the way oh I thought you said he throws
like a baby or something no he he throws
fives
no I I just said that it's like a father
and son playing that's true yeah
come on now son
it's God what a weirdo man what a weird
[__] what a weird thing to do hey
love how crazy does this look to you
very crazy I've never seen anything like
it yeah
like it's way this kind of stuff in my
opinion makes it more normal when you
have like people like Putin going like
shoot a sniper rifle you know what I
mean all right it looks normal in
comparison to this like this is weird
what the [__] are you doing
well we have a lot of Republicans who
are running based on their ability to
shoot weapons so it's a big announcement
yeah they should do that instead I like
that more session
the man knows how to throw a ball I'll
tell you what though man I'll tell you
what boy I don't know I wasn't sure
about that ROM DeSantis buddy he's got a
good arm on him to accomplish things
look how he throw a pretty good form he
just looks sloppy too like and you're
like breathing you're like panting
panting while you're like trying to go
through uh yeah I'll be I'll be a good
guy in the white house if uh the
legislative session works well it's like
that's this is such an awful format you
know what's funny too if you imagine
them in the white boots oh God that
would be awesome yeah he's probably
wearing them so there it is Ron DeSantis
is making some some Headway there
actually a story came out this week
about how weird Ron is behind the scenes
here's a quote enshrined and DeSantis
lore is an episode from four years ago
during a private plane trip from
Tallahassee to Washington
DeSantis enjoyed a chocolate pudding
dessert by eating it with three of his
fingers oh demon oh no that's lizard
[__] according to two sources familiar
with the incident no that's a lizard
person straight up like that's you know
Trump would never do that that's a
[__] hit Trump has some weird ass
like uh Trump does some weird ass [__]
too but like that wow that is weird
that's I mean I'm okay I I have an
announcement okay I I have an admission
a confession
I lick like the the tubs of containers I
do it very openly on my stream like I'll
lick like I'll lick the tub of container
clean sometimes the top or the whole tub
well it's like those little sauce
packets like yeah sweet green sauces
I'll like lick it I'm not judging you
just don't run for president
um but you can lick the top but the the
getting your tongue in like the pudding
well not the pudding container these are
sauce uh this is a little Ramekin this
man was eating it with his three good
even fingers but dumping three fingers
into a pudding cup
are you scooping it out like that that
shit's wild don't eat the pudding at
that point I like to feel the pudding on
my fingers
maximum feet what are you Winnie the
Pooh what the [__] is this yeah
what are you doing that's crazy in front
of other people like what the [__] this
is one of those things where you're like
you're high as [__] okay you're sitting
on the couch there's nacho cheese in
front of you right okay you ate all the
tortilla chips but there's still nacho
cheese left and you're high as [__] you
don't want to get up
that's when you dump the fingers and
when no one is looking God is always
watching but you do it on your own well
what's funny not on a [__] private
jet from Tallahassee to to Washington DC
in front of staffers and [__] well
what's funny is that is that this
apparently struck people so much three
two different people knocked on him
[Laughter]
we all remember that fateful dead and
that was sort of like I read the full
article and that was the thrust of the
entire thing is that it's just kind of
known that he's just a [__] weirdo
and I could have never guessed my life
yeah well I mean he is he is terrible on
camera yeah so that makes sense that
he's just like not very he's not very
charismatic so I'm not surprised that uh
he he has like weird fascinating things
like this that he does here is that from
a recent rally actually this explains
this picture
oh God okay it's pudding I guess
oh
actually watch out Rhonda santis and
Trump there's a new hat in the ring
and that hat is from the one and only
Joe Exotic running out of prison
can you run for first I didn't think you
could yeah you can't you know you can
you can Debs famous socialist ran from
prison read read the first paragraph
read the very beginning thank you for
your interest in my campaign yes I know
I am federal prison and you might think
this is a joke but it is not it is my
constitutional right to do this even
from here so can you become as a felon
in prison can you become president and
then pardon yourself
uh I don't know how that would work not
if it's a state crime
because the president can only pardon
federal crimes is he in for a State
Crime I I don't know that's kind of Epic
like yes sir I'm president now
I'll pardon all prisoners in the whole
country oh it was a federal jury that he
was convicted by so yeah he could he
could pardon himself yeah Eugene B Debs
ran for president 1920 election while
imprisoned in the Atlanta Federal
Penitentiary and he famously received
almost 1 million votes actually 3.4
percent slightly less than he had won in
1912 when he received six percent the
highest number of votes for a Socialist
Party presidential candidate in the
United States shouts out to Eugene V
Debs
he is a candidate uh video
what is what is gay as a three dollar
bill mean I think it's just like odd
because it's queer yeah right so why
don't you say queer then I don't know
maybe he just wanted to make sure that
people understand he's gay what's queer
mean queer can also be odd right like
people yeah old school people used to
use it as like odd yeah
so I think that's why he's just like I'm
gay I'm gay
which I mean we know I'm as gay as a
three dollar bill second of all I've had
some of the kinkiest sex you've ever
seen all right bad way to start your
[__] pitch for presidency hey what is
he was he mandating gay sex like what
that's right is that what is
what what possibly could be the kinkiest
sex you've ever seen like man this guy
gets up at his own weird [__] I bet it
includes those [__] Tigers now that'd
be kinky it's kind of wild how much this
man captivated the entire country
because we were just like locked in our
houses at the time and there was nothing
else going on so awesome so everyone was
like what's up with Tiger King like he
just kind of ran the
he was already dominated everything here
what he was our president during that
year yeah
right I tried drugs what the hell do you
think is
step back and lie about all this
[__] I'm broke as [__] I know
nothing about politics but I can goddamn
guarantee you I listen to The People's
voices not the rich people not the court
of America I listen to the people that
are playing the salaries of all you
bastards right but you know the coolest
thing about running a campaign is you
put it all out there on the table they
either like you or they don't like you
and ain't got nothing to talk about
trust me on that one right there
interesting pitch okay not bad all right
oh he's got my vote yeah
he's got endorsements who's endorsed him
oh random ass people
Carol bassey's endorsement locked hold
on this guy this girl has who are these
people well apparently like this guy for
example has 1.2 million what is that
like Jake Paul from Walmart what the
hell is that let's click Jesse Meester
the [__] is this photo brother 1.2
million followers up all of his likes
are hidden let me see how many comments
he's got on that
uh they're also hidden somehow it was
only liked by two people actually oh it
wasn't even hidden 1.3 1.2 million
followers okay now this one has 22 000
likes okay but it's botted I think so
how many comments
let's see well you can tell from the
comments if it's about it it says this
is body comment yeah
great picture my dear heart yeah this is
about it yeah he just didn't buy
anything for the other one yet Jesse
okay well he endorsed um [__] why don't
you can add us
yeah I endorse you you can climb a
zombie I don't know if I endorse them
yet I gotta hold off wait I want to get
involved bro can you imagine donating to
him
become a volunteer where's that money
going
there are a lot of things you could yeah
exactly I think this is the most amount
of like interest this campaign has ever
gotten
including in 2016
yeah so there it is the competition is
fierce everybody's saying that guys was
on 90 Day Fiance
okay well there it is he's got real
credibility yeah when it comes to
endorsing presence yeah he endorsed Joey
because he's going to open up the
immigration uh restrictions here's where
make it more restrictive so he can I
guess get out whichever whichever part
of 90 Day Fiance he was whichever way
he's trying to go
here's one a conservative author who
wrote a book about how Wellness is
destroying the youth in our country oh I
love this one
was asked a very simple question in fact
it's concerned during an interview uh
they asked her I'm gonna go pee while
this place I watched it already go ahead
they asked her what is wokeness
which is not a bad question you know it
is somewhat you can Define it in a few
different ways and as someone who's
written a whole book on the topic
you would think that she would be
relatively prepared uh with an answer
she is a rising star apparently in
conservative circles called and her name
is Bethany Mendel
where about development Dell effect on
her ass when she doesn't exist tomorrow
oh you freaking got her so good thanks
bro so here is the best and brightest
Minds
um
defining wokeness kind of Americans
consider themselves very liberal and
probably fewer of them consider
themselves to be woke and so you know
when when what does that mean to you
would you mind the finding well because
it's come up a couple times I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
well that no
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean
[Laughter]
she just had this um oh God it reminds
me of when Jesse Wellens had that moment
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah this is uh he
knows that yeah he just he knows he's
bombing oh that's so funny why did you
say that out loud is something that's
very hard to Define and we've spent an
entire chapter defining it
it is sort of the understanding that we
need to re totally reimagine and re
reduce Society in order to create
hierarchies of Oppression
um
it shouldn't be I mean you're you're an
authority on the damn thing incredible I
mean it's just the same principle behind
CRT they used to say CRT and then people
were like I don't know that sounds a
little complicated can't understand it
now they say woke which is like an old
which was like basically what they used
to say all the time ultimately all it
means is like uh in the in the ipso
study that we covered here on the show
last week you know covers it perfectly
well it's just me social justice like if
you're if you're aware of inequalities
in society that means you're woke and
that's somehow a bad thing now people
like uh Bethany Mandel
very famously who was written for
forward magazine about how we should
befriend neo-nazis
she wrote that uh Bethany Mandel who
very famously uh talked about how she
tried to be an anti-massacre
and like she she was a big anti-master
originally and like she posted a photo
of her like child's mask or something
and it was just like full of [__] it was
really weird it looked like a diaper
full of doo-doo
um
it you know she just keeps getting owned
on the timeline regularly this person
also has like some liberal Tendencies I
guess though he's supposed to be like
center right which is why she can't just
like come out of the gate swinging and
be like woke means you think black
people are human and I don't like that
but ultimately that's what it is can I
say something that
might get me buttoned but
I'm just being honest There's No Malice
to what I'm saying this is genuinely
what I thought from the best of my heart
Dan is shaking his head No Love Don't
everybody's saying no to me literally do
it just move on just don't do it if you
have a bad idea that needs to be
buttoned don't do it I think that's a
good thing
to dance you did no
just just write it in the Discord and
all uh he already I know exactly well I
want to tell his son you guys are
ruining you guys all right okay can you
see am I in the leftovers discard yeah
yeah just write it in the Discord and
I'll see what you're gonna say I kind of
want to see if Dan knows what you were
gonna say he does everyone is vetoing oh
you did
this is it this is it I can't see it
what is it I mean it's my J it's my
honest take no no do not say that do not
say that do not say that that's crazy
what no yeah what the [__] what no
okay no that's the absolute veto no it's
it's not even good okay we're moving on
from that it's not it's only it's not
even good it's just
no benefits for me as well no no no all
right anyway moving on I'm just gonna
say it no no no don't say it I'm gonna
hit the button if you do no
okay
okay God
so Jesus Christ
is it was it that bad love yeah he said
veto too literally everyone in this
building I'm not asking you Dan I asked
love okay dude memes whatever but like
politician on a politics show no or
whatever I don't know no no no no no no
definitely don't say that uh okay
um all right
why later at a later date and uh off
camera I can explain to you why that's
like inappropriate but anyway regardless
I'm not your child I know but like he's
right though what do you mean I do this
literally professionally for a living
obviously hundreds of thousands of
adults I asked you guys right yeah yeah
so thank you very much it's we we can
like talk about it later but do you
agree kind of in what I said like maybe
no no you don't even agree no I don't
even agree with it and also it's just no
it's just my spit take no um anyway
regardless getting back to the point at
hand
um
a lot of conservative ideology basically
revolves around what I like to call you
know Vice signaling you know how they
used to say like oh you're virtual
tingling like you're a liberal you're
virtually learning what is virtue
signaling the idea that like you don't
actually truly hold on to these beliefs
that like uh you know emancipation is a
necessity for marginalized communities
or anything like that and you're simply
saying that even if you don't believe in
it right which is a weird concept like
because half the time the virtues are
like everyone should have [__] health
care right
um
what conservatives do for the most part
is the opposite of that where they Vice
signal where basically they're like I'm
a piece of [__] like that's my politics
my politics is about like being mean and
awful to other people and then like the
more awful and the more of a piece of
[__] I am to certain groups of
individuals like the more people should
celebrate me for doing that right very
weird very weird concept but it's always
funny when the person who's supposed to
be the authority on the matter has a
hard time describing what their
perspective is has a hard time basically
saying like oh wokeness is about this or
that and here's why I'm against it so
you know that that video like Bethany uh
correctly called out went viral just
like many of our other Antics
um her defense for it was hilarious too
she was like well oh let me pull that up
yeah
so obviously it did go viral as she
predicted like you said and um because
again she looks like such a [__] and
well she is
she said so everybody's seeing my viral
brain fart from rising this morning I
can see why it went viral of course for
those who haven't here it is
interesting uh tactic here to share it
there's a big bit of a backstory she's
trying to own it she's trying to own it
dude listen to this just before we went
live Brianna Joy was on a hot mic I
heard her demeaning parents in general
and colorful and nasty terms stating
parents only have kids in order to pitch
perpetuate their own narcissism Robbie
responded there are some good ones and
some bad ones
gnarly she says as a mom of six
including a new board this just threw me
off yeah she was shocked into submission
devastating on me dude
she was devastated by it like why they
did not say that by the way like even if
she did why like what the [__] like what
what benefit does that have for you you
just seem like she almost seems and I
dare I say snowflake-ish yeah and so
sensitive yeah you need to be less woke
man so sensitive lady
like uh she she crumbled like a tissue
paper in the the first sight of an
anti-natalist you know what I mean and
by the way I saw somebody uh timed it
this was like six or seven minutes into
the interview not like right at the very
right so
okay so someone else actually had a
really good counter to this because she
was like a recently mother a recent
mother you know she's traumatized by
someone being like I don't want to have
children meanwhile she's had six
apparently is that what she said six
kids okay maybe you should stop having
kids Bethany okay you thought about that
maybe you are a little bit of a
narcissist for having six [__]
children Jesus Christ what are you doing
do you need Farm hands no why the [__]
do you need six children anyway whatever
maybe she does need Farm hands I got me
working on them what is this like that I
get why the Amish do it but what are you
doing anyway
um no well I think you're right they
have this vision of it's almost like a
white it's like they need to perpetuate
the white race kind of thing isn't it
yeah they're they're defending the white
race one uh you know one baby at a time
but
um the the other God damn it what was I
gonna say I'm like I'm I'm my brain is
Warped just like I recently had had a
child oh
um Bethany there was a tweet about
Bethany Mandel about how she pulled the
she pulled her mother off of life
support before she knew that her mom
could survive or not
real life she literally has done this
that's crazy how do people know why
would she say that she tweeted about it
she's like I killed my mom today
also abortion should be illegal that's a
wild overshare I mean here I found it I
found it it didn't even delete it it's
like literally there I took my mom at La
off life support at 16 dad killed
himself three years later grew up in a
trailer park I has sad for trumps is
what she said she has tweeted about it
before well she was 16 when it happened
um she this is not the tweet that I was
referencing though but this is the one
that I could immediately find but there
was another tweet from her literally
talking about how she pulled her mom off
of life support before she could know
whether she was viable or not she's also
she aborted her in a sense yeah but like
if my mom died I took her off life
support before we knew if she would
survive because I had the choice to do
it then what the [__] I think she was
saying that as a as like a
like a mark against abortion though like
I think she's saying like I killed my
mom and I feel really excited about that
and it doesn't go across saying like
abortion is just like that it seems to
me that she's happy she had the option
to kill her mom it seems like she didn't
like her mom this isn't a reply to
anything yeah
one faithful November evening she
decided to [__] let everyone on
Twitter know in 2014 that she [__]
murdered her mom she did active
euthanasia to her mom well not active
technically I treated mom like an
unwanted fetus and aborted her
therefore abortion should be legal no
you just killed a woman uh I watched my
mom die I took her off of life support
before we knew if she would survive
because I had the choice to do it
that's therefore choice is bad
yeah it's very odd she's like I I
murdered my mom that's why you shouldn't
be able to you should have to forcibly
carry pregnancies the term is weird but
we know she's at least practicing what
she preaches she's at six okay to be
honest her mom was like a fully formed
human ironic by the way again
Jewish could technically get all the
abortions she wants and it would be
legal right it'd be kosher yes uh yeah
according to Judaism like the fast and
hard rule is life begins at first breath
yeah so we be just [__] Throne so
that would be murder which she did
abortions not murder Bethany yeah
so anyway shout out to uh conservative
rising star and mother killer
yeah no she's been rising for a minute
she's she's old school like she's been
around that's why that's why I had a
bunch of old tweets of hers that I could
like very easily pull up she gets owned
regularly but they still put her on TV
and I bet you know what Bethany is
rising unlike her mom's life uh or her
mom's uh life support which is you wanna
you wanna find the math tweet too it's
gross as [__] it's like Ted Cruz tonsils
level gross wait what
oh my God is that her that's her yeah
wait what I remember that tweet yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she got 28 000 quote
tweets on that bad boy here I'll show
you wait what is it he was an
anti-masker she was an auntie man here I
I linked it I LinkedIn I mean trigger
warning this [__] is nasty as [__] here
I'm pulling it up
this mask is like the this after one day
that's hers yeah related how strange is
it that progressives scaring their
children into wearing dirty bacteria
filled cloth on their face for eight to
nine hours a day without complaint as
evidence of their amazing parenting she
breathed the star she got that doo-doo
mouth she got like toxic that's like
this is what I don't understand like
what is why is the outside of the Mask
nasty what the [__] is your kid doing
wait are you sure that's her kids mask I
think that was the context of this yeah
she says it in a reply to it she says
this is a child's mask this is one day
of use of on a small child use on a
small child technically she said says
this is one day of use on a small child
so maybe she like she doesn't say that
it's used as a mask so I'm just still
holding on hope that that wasn't maybe
her young child is a pack a day smoker I
was just gonna say that and smokes
through the mask which puts it up
Bethany the Marlboro Reds please I know
you cut me off the [__] Menthol [__]
give me the cowboy kill is Bethany it's
hard being your [__] six-year-old
[__]
we haven't touched on any of the main
topics here
[Laughter]
well we we're only halfway through the
episode so we we got time if we start to
run out 30 almost well we started we're
an hour in we're exactly yeah okay all
right you wanna you want me to leave is
that what no you have to leave I'll do
this all day if you want to you're the
one that's always running out of here
Ben Shapiro by the way love that and oh
this one's good nobody doubts that Ben
Shapiro is like
a bad boy with he's boy Witten Boy
Wonder on the right he's smart he's in
Philly
listen to this take Bible tighten it
into like the champion he's trying to
rationalize why feeding low-income kids
is bad
yeah well he doesn't even say it's bad
it's really this is a great video Let's
watch let's take a look at what he has
to say because he doesn't even say that
it's bad like which makes it even
funnier he says it's cheap and good but
we still shouldn't do it
so there's like a whole back and forth
that was good let me let me follow this
thread here
um Ben responded to him too I sent that
one originally they're both in there I
just started with the video because
that's where it's I [__] ratio the
[__] out of Ben by the way I don't know
why you didn't put that oh you on the
daily wire now I didn't see it what now
you're on the daily wire as well that's
how that works okay so here's what he
said yeah I'm giving I'm giving Stephen
Carter 100 million dollars
is that kids from the sick radical
election they also protect kids from
Hunger when it makes sense to strengthen
food stamps and have school lunch be
free since some kids are in school lunch
debt uh well I mean if you are a parent
school lunches are not going to solve
the problem of child hunger at any
serious level wrong there is a problem
of children nationally starving that is
a child endangerment scenario in which
CPS needs to be called insane they do
that already the truth is it does not
take that much money to feed a child I
know I'm also wrong
this is like the most out of touch
[__] gift piece of [__] he's such a
dude yeah he's just [__] worth 25 min
million dollars like literally I don't
understand I have children it's super
easy to feed them like how much can a
banana cost Michael uh fifty dollars
like that's that's literally said it
doesn't cost that much to feed a kid I
have three of them feeding kids is if
you're not super [__] well off very
expensive dude you know what's awesome
also like on top of that everything else
like again net worth 25 million dollars
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about totally talking out of his ass I
don't have children even I know that's
expensive as [__] right kids are but
like because he's right wing no one
considers this to be like a faux pas you
know what I mean incredible he's like
poor kids should die yeah now Orchid
should starve a couple components I have
to touch on here okay let me finish the
clip okay finish the clip yeah before
you feed yourself
does not take that much money to feed a
child I know I have three of them uh the
you should be feeding your child before
you feed yourself it's that simple yeah
much deeper problem at work than school
lunches if kids are legitimately
starving okay welcome to America brother
we do have problems [__] idiot like
how how are you the smartest
conservative okay here here are some
here are some fundamental facts here uh
I'm gonna I I talked about it briefly on
my quote retweet as well there are nine
million children that are food insecure
in the United States of America fact
number one fact number two America
produces an abundance of food okay we
have enough food for not just the United
States of America but pretty much for
the rest of the planet the the the idea
that like someone is dying of hunger in
the United States of America is insanely
cruel and inhumane the idea that we have
children that are in food insecure
households in the United States of
America is again cruel and insane it's
because agricultural producers who are
heavily subsidized by the federal
government by the way and it would not
exist if it wasn't for Central planning
in the form of federal subsidies
refuse
to give out additional food for free
because that would uh really
significantly lower food prices okay so
when you're thinking about inflation
when you're thinking about how expensive
food is remember that okay we are our
federal government your tax dollars are
actually helping uh offset a lot of the
cost of food production which then comes
back to your uh you know which which
comes to your grocery stores and it's
expensive because someone needs to make
money along the line it reminds me of
that scene from Grapes of Wrath where
they're burning oranges yeah I don't
know if you read that book yeah I did
read that book Steinbeck is is great
yeah Mr socialist
everybody's starving starving during the
uh Great Depression
and the farmers have Surplus oranges
this I'm assuming actually happened
people put it in the book yeah and they
would they were happening right now they
were trekking at California from cross
country and they would walk across
fields of oranges being burned to keep
the prices high they didn't have to feed
give them away to starving people yeah
so it's cruel it's disgusting it's
capitalism it's the way of life baby so
that's number one so we have an
abundance of food it's just a logistics
problem it's just because you know we
don't want to we don't want to lower the
price of food too much right so that's
number one all right that's number two
number three do you want to know what
the most uh calorically dense food that
these food insecure households get the
children of these food insecure
households get School breakfast programs
and school lunches that is precisely the
reason why there's a major point of
contention here with school lunches the
fact that you have to pay for school
lunches or the fact that you have to
work to pay your school lunch debt in
the richest nation on Earth is not only
laughable but also again insanely
[__] cruel and Ben would know any
number of these facts if he gave a [__]
about what he's talking about instead of
just constantly talking out of his ass
about how he doesn't give a [__] about
anything and vice signaling it's
interesting that he
care so much about kids I mean he cares
about uh kids being what they're taught
in school he cares about the fact that
they have a right to be born he cares so
much about kids but when it comes to
like the most basic necessity of taking
care of children here who aren't part of
his super affluent family outside of his
basic nuclear family he wants him to
[__] starve and the solution is just
call CPS yeah government big government
by the way you know you know who gets
traffic dude Children of the foster care
system but you don't give a [__] because
those are poor kids you know what I mean
a lot of times those are black and brown
kids you don't give a [__] about that
because you don't care about children
okay if you did you would know like I
said school lunches and School breakfast
programs are profoundly important in
combating food insecurity food
insecurity in households food insecurity
and children in general because uh you
know it's it's also very important for
the development as well if they don't
get enough food if they're malnourished
they're not going to develop adequately
so this theory of college CPS is on as
as stupid as saying sell your house when
it goes under sea level yeah he says
he's saying if you're too poor to feed
your child then we need to put them in
foster care you're talking about
millions of kids who are more poor so
you want to set up like uh FEMA camps
full of parentless kids and then what we
have to feed them there apparently they
have parents they just their parents are
working in a lot of instances these food
insecurities
do we give the camps of foster children
uh food do we give them yeah we can give
them we can give them lunches once
they're in the FEMA camp okay good good
I just got to make sure because I don't
know mind-boggling that Mr save the
children you know cares about children
Mr small government's solution to an
otherwise like
very effective and not all that costly
problem which you could eliminate by
just funding it okay his solution is not
to literally do this cheap thing which
is to make sure that there is no such
thing as lunch debt eradicate that and
give them food children food at schools
which by the way is so important and
this is better than the fact that I have
to mentioned here it's so important that
during covet when schools closed they
still kept school lunches did you know
this in many states even those schools
were closed school lunch programs
continued that is how important school
lunches are in combating child
malnourishment and food insecurity in
households in the United States of
America where once again I repeat myself
nine million children
are suffering from food insecurity let's
take those nine million kids let's put
them in account he wants to break down
nine million [__] doors with the
government at the same time at the same
time he goes the problem with this
country is kids without dads so here's
my solution let's take the poorest among
them and take them away from their dads
yeah
you're not a serious person you're
[__] just an evil [__] bro you're an
evil [__] [__] you he goes Ted Ted uh
actually California Senator right big
teddy boy
we love Ted don't we do we love you he's
all right he's just he's okay
whatever uh well anyway he responds he
says Dear bench bear your marks are dumb
let's do math say kids should eat 21
meals a week school lunch and provide
five of those meals solving nearly
one-fourth of the problem that's pretty
good
oh
and how about you miss one of your meals
five days a week and see how you feel
okay let me go now to Ben's response
where he doubles down he says Dear Ted
if you think the key
thing standing between kids and
starvation is school lunch that's silly
have you looked
into this at all no this is literally he
is openly stating an incorrect statement
like it's so frustrating to me when I
see [__] like Ben just so
loudly and proudly demonstrate their
ignorance on a subject because it is the
exact opposite yes it quite literally is
standing between kids and starvation
school lunches are the most calorically
dense meal that food insecure households
get for their children it is a [__]
fact it is such a well-established fact
that like I said during covert when
schools closed the lunch programs
continued they usually have it during
summer as well in order to facilitate
additional calorically dense food
substitutes now a lot of you will say
well the sun I went to public school in
America and the food was dog [__] you
mean to tell me that these children nine
million of them are possibly eating that
food and that is the best type of food
that they can get yes also that's how
[__] dire the situation is in the
United States usually like super
that like suits like pizza and [__]
yeah burritos shouts out to Amy
Klobuchar for making pizza a vegetable
that's the uh but that's calories
and calories you [__] care exactly
exactly we don't have to worry about
nutrition when you're starving okay
people who cannot comprehend especially
like listen we're we're wealthy people
living in the [__] lap of luxury in
sunny California Los Angeles it it is
hard for us to comprehend how this [__]
Works listen I got two kids I know how
cheap it is no I'm just saying like it
it blows my mind just like read a
[__] book dude read a book read an
article read a journal read a study one
study one study read one book like
something that is okay to get wrong it's
not like we're talking about some you
know
[__]
Sidetrack [__] we're talking about
children who you basically obsess over
dot [__] starving starving for
example let's see 17 thousand six
hundred and eighty three kids were given
puberty blockers between 2017 and 2021
that's four years that's not a lot
versus nine million kids in America
starving yeah in 2020 14.8 percent of
households in the United States were
food insecure 14.8 percent this man
cares about kids but yet he's obsessed
with something that it affects less than
18 000 kids over four years
what's like objectively bad starvation
yeah well I mean I I don't know it's
like uh you have much larger problems if
uh you're starving if you don't get your
food yeah it's like he's not even wrong
yeah we are in that situation and we do
have much larger problems and it's not
being made any better by [__]
[__] like you who get paid by like
all the billionaire Oil Barons to ensure
that this system of Oppression continues
while you [__] repeat American
Enterprise Institute talking points from
like 1994 I [__] hate this piece of
[__] so much he's just I can't get over
the people think he's smart or
interesting I mean this tweet there's 6
500 people who are like yes I support
American children starving he literally
doubles down and six thousand five
hundred and ninety seven [__] like
that Starving Children please I want the
CPS to come in and break their [__]
doors down and separate them forcibly in
my game how do they like it where does
Ben live is it in L.A no he lives in
Florida he lives in Florida now oh did
he leave it might it might it might very
publicly I live in Nashville but then
now he lives in Florida okay man can you
imagine him anyway he goes in my gator
community in Florida I have never seen
one kid starving okay at the private
school I go to their lunches are
beautiful very nice nobody's starving
there so I I just don't get it like if
my neighbor's kids were starving I I
called CPS because something's wrong I
mean they're billionaires why aren't
they feeding their kids and so so so I
just don't get it you know poor and
anyway if poor kids die who cries
it really is he really doesn't get it if
poor kids die
if a poor kid starves in the forest does
anybody hear it it just blows my mind
again that like this person is not being
left out of every room that this person
is not being dunked on mercilessly that
this person is not belittled every
moment that he lives and people
genuinely think he's like a brilliant
guy if I don't care about your feelings
if I [__] I mean dude I I made a false
prediction about [__] Russia not
invading Ukraine even though my analysis
was sound a year ago and [__]
haven't let that [__] go meanwhile Ben
Shapiro says this as a like as a part of
his job like this is his daily rhetoric
all the [__] time focus on important
[__] like this dumbasses there's a
there's a kid Starving in the street
he's panhandling he's begging for food
he says I bet your spirit goes facts
don't care about your feelings
spits in his face the child eagerly eats
it open there's calories in it [__] you
[__]
horrible
it's so it's so immoral it's it's just
like it's so cruel yeah it's actually
disgusting and his wife
his wife's a doctor
my God man what happened to the hippo
hypocritical oath more like
yeah
good I'm sure I'm not the first one to
say that
yeah but it's true that was good thank
you real good so that's Ben Shapiro I
think we should change this how to Ben
Shapiro says let them kids die
yeah
it's [__] up kids yeah so okay moving
moving on uh speaking of uh Darlings on
the right who are also super smart and
always right crap Stephen Crowder's
making his comeback oh thank God I've
been waiting dude the Mud Club is back
that's right
after resoundingly rejecting the daily
wires 50 million dollar contract
in the in the pursuit of freedom
seven days uh left while we fight like
hell he says uh here we go
Mud Club professionally it's meant
everything to us here huh
we here at Mud Club are in the business
of serving you
my viewer you this whole thing about mug
Club the way they use it is so
embarrassing it's like you're just
talking about like people paying you for
a [__] month patreon
thank you dude it's patreon brother
that's what it is is only Clans like
that's what it is it's just like if you
want the juicy [__] like if you want to
to hear me say all the slurs like I'm
gonna read all the slurs off like you
know buy this ugly ass mug
um
listen it's like a focus program like
we're members club uh
I don't know the funniest part about the
funniest part about this stuff of course
is that like like for example
the majority of my Revenue comes from
subscribers at twitch right twitch takes
a percentage of that it's fine whatever
you know you gotta you gotta do what you
gotta do right that's where that's how I
make my money but part of that is also
because I don't have billionaire Oil
Barons that are like please here is like
50 million dollars so you can tell
everyone how [__] dog [__] we are you
know what I mean because I don't rush to
defend Mega corporations like Stephen
Crowder does he has all of that he gets
the rumble deals and on top of that he's
doing the mug club for the additional
racism on the side I mean hey you got to
do what you got to do I guess he's set
man
you are the entire reason for our
ability your ability to create this kind
of content truly stop they did not put
that video on there oh yeah thank you
guys thank you for supporting mug Club
where I can you know live my best gay
life on camera only as I talk about how
awful it is to to be a a gay person bro
this man is like a that's Fire Company
we're King I think dude that's fire
content thank you Stephen that's I'm so
glad this is why I'm a mug Club guy
let me do a slow-mo on this that kind of
good ass content playback
quarter
this is why we're on the Mud Club
[Music]
oh brother Stephen
that wasn't just a phase in college man
I
I mean I think he knows that but anybody
else all right let's keep going let's
see let's see what else you got
[Music]
I joined Mud Club I resent the fact that
they're actually pitching this like a
comedy show
strength and free speech and I want it
back now we need to go out remember what
it's all about it's about our children
it's about our future it's about our
safety not the Stars stop every second
bro listen
at most you're doing like shitty ass SNL
skits like what do you mean protecting
the children like this is what I get mad
at whenever [__] are like
Hassan you you're supposed to be
socialist Jesus I'm like no man I'm just
a [__] dumbass I'm a content creator
I'm an Entertainer okay that's what I do
uh I try to I try to educate people I
try to agitate people to understanding
like what the [__] going on in society
but that's it I don't run around being
like I'm saving I'm saving the planet by
uh you know with my skits I'm saving the
planet once get at a time this is the
this is what's so [__] annoying about
like SNL or like the smarmy magnetic or
not magnanimous the smart the smarmy
sanctimonious attitude that a lot of
like liberals have with respect to their
art right he's doing the same exact [__]
crazy
who's he saving with this is he really
do people watch Crowder because they
think he's funny or like no I think
people do people do actually find him
funny uh yeah I guess when the
competition is Roseanne Barr I guess
maybe he does come off pretty good
and like that other [__] guy that
just like makes donkey sounds what's his
name from halfway Jim Brewer wow the bar
is low over there
I need to go out and remember what it's
all about it's about our children it's
about our future it's about our safety
it's about our country
channels would you be willing to trade
all the dates from this day to that
[Music]
he is way more of a theater kid than me
brother oh 100 yeah yeah I don't want to
see you alongside me fighting like hell
but like hell you just showed a bunch of
cringy sketches where you yeah no he's
actually out here he is literally doing
the exact same thing that people
criticize liberals for doing okay it's
so self-important it's like bro you are
literally making [__] ass sketches
that's all you're doing you're yelling
at like hysterical College freshmen who
don't know the Talking Tree okay that
you are like using lines from uh that's
that's your content that's all you do
and and yet for some reason like
conservatives look at it and they they
lap it up they're like oh my God he's
safe in the planet dude the [__] he's
saving so all he's saving is you know
his pockets I guess Stephen Crowder who
rejected 50 million dollars a daily wire
obviously got a pretty fat offer from
Rumble uh where yesterday we watched
snico dance around with a gun and
threatened to kill people yeah platform
so it's a good platform yeah Rumble
remember I guess rumble's our number one
draft pick I guess well hopefully we're
a draft pick for you guys too Rumble
betting on ourselves and Rumble as a
hedge on those bets because they
actually uh nobody cares bro you're not
that [__] important I don't know I
think I think here's my lock I think
that
the Stephen Crowder Ben Shapiro Rift
actually was more beneficial for Stephen
Crowder and was actually not very good
for Ben Shapiro on The Daily wire I
think a lot of people and this is the
same principle behind like Donald
Trump's success and why he like
frustrates so many conservatives is that
whoever feeds into the base by being
more extremists and being even dumber
and being even more racist wins the
battle I think I don't know I I I I yeah
I didn't really understand the Dynamics
of how he came out on top because like
he
he started it they gave him like the
most insanely generous and lucrative
deal
and I didn't really but yeah apparently
people liked it I I don't get it I don't
get it yeah you don't get it but I told
you even back then like 50 million bucks
you guys whoever is dumber he's spitting
their face for them whoever is dumber
wins because the audience is [__]
stupid that's it that's like
whoever did the most goo goo gaga [__]
in that situation and looked more like a
[__] petulant child won that argument
I mean he came out of the gate swing and
he said daily wire doesn't want me to be
racist even though they were hiring me
to be racist okay but they don't want to
[__] pay me if I get banned for my
racism and that's [__] and people
were like yeah that's right actually I
like that he's honest he's got Integrity
well good on Rubble you can say whatever
the [__] you want so you're King there
anyway here he is talking with his
cohort Russell Brand who also has a show
on Rumble who is just turned into the
biggest hack my God who is he I was on
radio right yeah the FCC and they would
say you can't say for example you can
say uh I think that uh Harry Reid is a
dick you can't say hey Harry Reid has a
small dick right that was what they said
they said you can say ah crap you can't
say I took a crap these rules that were
silly but it was kind of a game of cat
and mouse here with the FCC nothing
scatological everyone is the FCC what
happens is YouTube says well you won't
be able to make a living and more
importantly no one will be able to find
your videos unless you are Advertiser
friendly and it's unless you don't say
the n-word like their rules are so yeah
dude like relax bro what do you mean you
cannot compare YouTube to FCC like you
can we get away you can say pretty much
anything yeah other than like straight
up uh insane nonsensical
like openly white supremacists yes
so you have to [__] up so bad yeah like
like recreating the execution of George
Floyd while making it possible for that
I think I don't know
but like you should you should get ding
for that that's fine yeah no that's
insane no it's insane it's insane it is
like on Tick Tock how we talk about how
like over the top their censorship is
that I get if you're gonna criticize but
YouTube is probably on the whole
internet besides Rumble which is
basically just pedophiles and Nazis as
we say yeah um
the most accepting of diverse viewpoints
and yeah that's a very positive way to
put it it seems like Susan's gone Ethan
you don't have to say these any any
longer unless you got it in with the
news at the end of the day
compared to what's out there YouTube is
pretty crowded incredible no I just
meant like you're you're
saying is a diversity of opinions but
it's just like YouTube
it's not as bad as the diversity of
opinion not diversity let's get it
straight Jack it's not diversity is
cancer it's not as bad as it used to be
it used to be significantly worse
because like there was a direct pipeline
to white supremacist rhetoric you know
like I'm talking Richard Spencer like
open neo-nazis were able to to to
congregate in certain right-wing spaces
the Centrist essayists to uh Richard
Spencer pipeline was very viable alive
and well for Sargon to Richard
um it doesn't exist anymore as as much
but you can still get away with saying a
lot of horrific [__] which Matt Walsh
does which Ben Shapiro does all the time
yeah and the daily wires asked was
Stephen just like you know
dog whistle a little bit more you don't
have to always bullhorn it but but this
is Steven understands the audience
better than Ben does well you need the
bullhorn the Perpetual victimhood is
really powerful for selling them mugs
yeah far more strict because it's not
just naughty words you can't cover and
so people are self-centering I'm gonna
listen to most of the podcasts out there
right now it is far more PG vanilla
Disney friendly than what you would hear
on basic AM radio that's bro so not we
spent 90 minutes talking about [__]
yesterday like that's just so not true
it's so yeah but he would say you're
you're a lip card and that's why like
you're allowed to do it when he's not
allowed to do it or something I can't
even he goes man I tried to do a
90-minute segment about why the uh bell
curve is 100 scientific and accurate and
they told me you probably could do that
actually [__] that would be like a
totally I don't think you'd get a strike
for that no you I don't think you get in
trouble at all for that
anyway so welcome back um to the mix
there Steve the goat right finally I I
was I was waiting I was waiting for like
you know who's to go who
Jordan [__] Peterson oh my God my
benzo King so is he back on the he's
dude there's no shot he was tweeting
like that sober if he's tweeting like
that sober he's got bigger problems he's
well he does have big problems yeah this
man so I guess someone oh we had to
cover it yeah so somebody here for
whatever reason I guess it's a gag said
what's going on in China
it's not a gag that's like a super
anti-china account yeah yes they also
got tricked by I have a [__] bone to
pick with that account that account is
literally constantly posting about like
look at all these people in China that
are being brutally murdered in covet
camps and then it gets like 700 000
retweets every single time uh first of
all let me tell you something okay wait
let me just describe here
I don't even know what's their point but
there's a video they shared with clearly
white dudes apparently this is a UK uh
adult uh content yeah it's their white
dick milking Factory
it's actually quite quite interesting
yeah they got strapped up to [__]
hospital beds with a dick suck pump
machine it's like a utter an automatic
utter yeah and they all all three of
them just start getting their dicks
milks frankly yeah milked and Jordan
Peterson but remember PG content like
you're not allowed to talk about these
sorts of things that you would be able
to talk about on AM radio according to
Steven Carter shut the [__] up he says
he says what's going on in China three
children policy I don't even understand
like what he's trying to say but Jordan
Peterson of course quote tweeted this
milk factory porn and said such fun and
unbelievably techno nightmare CCP hell
first of all that is kind of fun I guess
like if they that's like a kink so those
guys in the UK which is where that was
yeah okay are are having fun so I guess
that is literally fun for them uh it's
not for me don't understand it but don't
go to the milking Factory then Jordan
but it's wild that he posted that didn't
think that that was like you know not a
good thing to post the video was so
weird it just show up on my feed the
night that he tweeted it and it stayed
up for like five hours before he finally
deleted the tweet and I cannot emphasize
how [__] graphic this video is yes
it's always on the floor it's not just
graphic it's just like one of the most
bizarre things yeah it's crazy
it is literally the dick sucking Factory
there is nothing else to describe there
like precisely but what is there what is
the propaganda here what what is dudes
getting there well he was saying like
three children policy like they're
they're dick sucking in China to like
forcibly impregnate people so they have
children or something yeah
you know but I thought they had too many
kids they did no that was all that's
over China China is now in their like uh
you know in their they're on their 80s
and 90s America [__] right now they have
like a robust middle class they have
like a lot of okay but what's the law in
China right now the there is no longer a
uh one child one child thinks it's gone
yeah so their theory is that
they're having as much kids as possible
now yeah they're saying that China has
going to just like any other developed
nation is going to uh have declining
birth rates which they are and not as
precisely why they want to like push for
uh children that's like the the argument
here and so they're milking dudes and
then I guess they have like a whole
insemination plan where they just put
people like cattle in a barn and that's
the implication that sounds kind of fire
if you say whatever you want about China
and people will believe it it's like
North Korea you could say whatever you
want about North Korea people will 100
believe it they don't give a [__]
there's no fact checking process and
it's also like already difficult as hell
to get like actually accurate
information out of North Korea anyway
um I can just imagine someone like
Jordan Peterson meeting like a Chinese
person be like so tell me what's going
on with the milking uh Farms there just
like being so utterly stunned and
confused by that as a Chinese person
I hear there's milking Farms have you
been milked over there
here's dude here's more I mean I get
more mad about this because like Xi
Jinping what are you [__] doing don't
let don't let this [__] uh Elon Musk
keep [__] [__] on China like this
you own him he needs the Shanghai
facilities just [__] give him a
little call and be like listen I'm the
top G okay what is this what is this
anti-china sentiment happen
you know oh this is the guy so please
restore my Tick Tock account and stop
letting me get banned on Tick Tock did
you get banned again no but you know I'm
just I'm just hedging my bets here am I
unbanned because I actually got I don't
know and uh maybe we should mention as
of last night it may all be moot because
uh Biden's trying to kind of get rid of
tick tock for real yeah it's [__] up I
mean it's actually not [__] up if I
keep getting banned then it's good but
if I don't get banned any longer and I
can use it then it's it's super [__]
bro I'm still [__] banned like it's
stupid
okay but anyway the guy who tweeted it
out made a a um he made a correction so
Props off to him he said sorry my
mistake I found this video on WeChat and
said they said this is China's
collection room for sperm bank turns out
this video is from the UK so here we go
very you know hey this guy's uh he's uh
wait he followed through wait go down
scroll down this is China's collection
oh he he said no this is China's
collection
don't show it yes
Ian you out there yeah he's off of it
all right I do want to see this though
he says this is China's collection room
for sperm the machine has already
registered a police wait so he's mad
about the [__] actual normal sperm
bank like I don't understand
yeah you know there's like sperm banks
in America right you have to do it
manually
wait I I I genuinely this guy's not a
real doctor I guarantee this is just
some weird I don't know what's happening
here but like if it's burning had that
if his birming had that and like why are
you mad at that I'm sure they sanitize
it uh it's like a single use suck master
you know what I mean I think he's he's
just desperate to make this but I don't
believe that either I bet this is a
[__] parody too there's no shot no
no or they're just trying to sell some
really what is what is what the dude
there's no way that's gonna help me
finish
[Music]
your place didn't just had like a dirty
chair Mr Beast bought 1 000 suck Masters
for real Chinese citizens to help the
declining birth rate what's up everybody
sucks that's awesome yeah so Jordan
Peterson's out there
actually we have a whole album of
bizarre tweets he's put out uh since
he's back on uh Xanax yeah my favorite
one was the CNN one but here we'll get
there it's all here
uh he's oh yeah this one was fire and
it's not a vagina it's a hole for a
mother another man to [__] and that's
that so the quote tweet for that is also
just a fake thing it's uh so a a Boston
Children's Hospital doctor is talking
about vaginoplasty right
um which is a a you know it's a it's a
surgical process so of course it sounds
[__] brutal just like every other
surgery is right
um and then because it's from the Boston
Children's Hospital and these guys are
[__] cavemen uh you know ape brain
dumbasses who don't understand that the
Children's Hospital doesn't only serve
children and that the Boston Children's
Hospital as a matter of fact
will only allow this elective surgery uh
of like vaginoplasty or reconstruction
bottom surgery most commonly known as
for adults consenting I'm going to open
adults over the age of 18. okay and it
doesn't just happen on a whim there's
like numerous other uh numerous other
things that you need to go through
numerous other checks that you need to
go through okay uh before you go through
with the surgery but of course he
[__] tweeted that and said prison uh
billboard Chris don't show this oh it's
just no this is a doctor talking about
it okay so here's the video that set
Jordan off of the sick hello inversion
vaginoplasty is the full name of
adenoplasty in this procedure the
surgical team is creating the outer and
the inner vagina the reason it's okay so
it's a doctor talking it's a doctor
talking about a penile inversion and
vaginoplasty okay that's like it's a
surgical process also commonly known as
like bottom surgery right
um here's what he said but they made it
seem like they're doing it on children
that's not true like you can't do this
surgery on children it is not allowed
you know however one surgery that
actually they do on children all the
[__] time when there's an intersex
child the doctor often more commonly uh
than not will choose the gender of the
child okay then they engage in not this
level of surgical process but this kind
of surgery where they you know sew up
the vagina if the child has like a
vagina and a penis at the same time you
know what I mean like intersex intersex
children intersects babies when they're
born the doctor gets to decide what
their [__] gender is in some
instances it's understandable to make
this decision depending on like uh you
know uh if it's like uh if it's going to
improve someone's quality of life and
some meaningful capacity sure except
it's still without the child's consent
oftentimes without the parents consent
and it's actually kind of horrific to do
so which is precisely the reason why
Boston Children's Hospital this Hospital
ban that process but you will never hear
these conservative [__] talk about
that kind of surgery that kind of
surgical process uh being like abhorrent
or awful or inhumane even though it
quite literally is now why won't they
say that because it it stands by and
reinforces the rigid gender binary
that's the real inhumane [__] not
consenting adults making uh making uh
surgical decisions on their own body
well Jordan said Gina of the process he
said and it's not a vagina it's a hole
for another man to [__] yeah that's that
right pull for another Amanda [__]
imagining you have a vagina like
you're disgusting man you're like super
[__] up yeah it's also weird even
weirder within the context because like
he's talking about children in his mind
he thinks he's talking about children's
holes and that is that is really the
weirdest and possibly my favorite he's
been on is
he keeps twitting out this random photo
from Looney Tunes
I cannot possibly discern what this
could mean or even what I'm looking at
here you have Porky Pig as a friar
presumably in some kind of Robin Hood
yes Daffy Ducks appears to be Robin Hood
of some sort I have no idea what this is
do we know what this is okay so and as
you'll see in this album he he tweeted
this out like four or five times over
the course of like a week I did track
down that cartoon I managed to find that
Looney Tunes cartoon and found that
exact part and
Daffy does say it is to laugh
at that moment so he in that tweet is
quoting it but even with
it y'all remember that y'all remember
that Looney famous moment the famous
random from like a from like a totally
obscure loony to it's like not even like
one of the more famous ones and even
with the context it still doesn't make
any sense it's like Daffy gets his head
stuck in a tree and then he makes a quip
oh this is a tree yeah that I was very
confused by looking at as well so Jordan
thought so he's really committed to this
he says committed to the bit of what the
bit is I have no [__] morning update
the Globe and Mail China diverts some
research to Canada blah blah blah he
says it is to laugh Justin Trudeau but
then he he continues with the he
continues with this image that's really
hard hitting Canada has room for
improvement he says
okay he continues yeah once again
sustainable Finance here this uh image
from Looney Tunes hits hard when in
terms of that and he continues even more
meaning really good he says review we're
way past review and then hits him with
the [__] Looney Tunes frame
and it's just really interesting that he
thought he was doing something with that
yeah he's on [__] crack that's why
he's doing this I mean not crack he's on
benzos probably here's the CNN one you
loved CNN tweeted our video says women
in Berlin can now swim topless in the
city's public pools if they choose to
it's being hailed as a step forward for
gender equality in the German Capital
Jordan responds absolutely go ahead
wait zoom in a little bit I'm having a
hard time reading because these are my
older glasses yeah absolutely everything
you do CNN is
that virtue
who spank good near days are numbered
that's that
that's the most Xanax yeah but what what
is what the [__] is CNN is literally
just report reporting on the news like
this is the most unbiased reporting on
in another country I wanna I wanna
explore his mind so bad does he think
CNN caused this to happen thank you yeah
me Mike CNN
like what the [__] does CNN have to do
with with what's going on in Berlin so
women's swimming topless is apparently
it's really bad but South amount it's
also CNN's fault yeah it's the dragon of
chaos has been Unleashed upon the public
pools of Berlin God forbid if I was in a
public pool and I saw some titties I
would [__] bust a nut right in my
swim shorts it'd be a disaster
my grandma's pubes would brush across my
phone oh God here we go okay what would
I do I saw my grandma topless once I
haven't stopped dreaming about it
my eyes would pop out like a Looney Tune
frame my mouth the frame my mouth my jaw
would drop to the ground my tongue would
roll out like the red carpet here's the
frame in which I'm referencing it from
Looney Tunes 1943 train before your
mirror at home tucking your dick between
your legs imagining you have a vagina or
sexual kick although it's nothing sexual
about that yeah right bloody absolutely
I would be screaming bloody murder
as hot steam would come out of my ears
CNN you pathetic virtue signaling
I would get chubbed up like a [__]
coat rack a cartoon coat rack this would
be me this would be me at the pool
reappropriated I love that
um he again we're we're focusing on the
right wing intellectuals here and they
are all so dysfunctionally [__] in the
head it's actually incredible they
constantly got like baby dicks and
vaginas in the mind it's like there's no
other way to describe it like you're
just constantly thinking about
children's genitals there's no way that
that is normal for you like there's no
way that's good for you and you know
seek help you know read the Quran okay
find God this is you know you're going
down a very weird path brother so this
is an old viral uh video I remember
watching this like probably 15 years ago
that's a crow surfing down
a snowy roof on like a leaf or some [__]
I mean this one is fire he's right about
this though crows and other corvids are
super smart super smart one word
yeah crows are pretty smart they can use
tools and stuff so I like that one see
he's got bangers dude you pray you can
Prager you he's now retweeting name one
way to fix America they asked pray
desperately Jesus I didn't know you're
so out of the closet as like a no he's
always been a big big time religious boy
no but he used to like tiptoe around it
like what does God even mean [__] out no
no he's always been he he definitely
always been in like a big uh advocate
for it uh Twitter suit the type dude
he's got one suit bro dude literally
just there's no way that [__] smells
good okay every time you see him on the
timeline he loves as who he wears all
the time the tie is composed of micro
Elon Musk heads as it should be
he's so he I noticed lately he
tags Elon to like back him up and [__]
nowadays he goes what do you think Elon
[__] burning cash dude
here's one oh this one was awesome okay
so he says sheer unadulterated net
narcissism in action I care so much the
devouring mother arises from the
underworld now I'm not into like uh you
know uh I don't really know too much
about uh Hindu gods and goddesses and
things of that nature but I do know that
uh Jordan Peterson has like a very solid
right-wing uh Indian audience and they
were very pissed off at him they were
[__] ripping him he like he directly
he directly pissed him off by posting
this almost like he doesn't know what
he's talking about when it comes to
anything yeah there I don't know what
I'm talking about with this with respect
to this either but I did see a bunch of
like uh BJP stands [__] being like
stay in your [__] Lane you piece of
[__] we only liked it when we're
shooting on Muslims shut the [__] up
he's definitely way out of his depth
here why are you talking about like
Hinduism and [__] yeah I believe that's
Shiva which is uh one of pretty much the
three top gods in Hinduism so he's
calling Shiva a devouring mother this
concept he's become obsessed with at
least he's like honestly at least he's
consistent though with his misogyny
where he's like true it's the dragon of
chaos what do you mean
uh this at your feet and people won't
forget it what happened in the UK with
the Travis stock will soon happen here
and you're on the wrong side of History
to be clear I mean oh no apparently it's
uh Kali uh k-a-l-i
goddess of ultimate power time
destruction and change yeah
um this one was just psycho that was
fire what do you mean he's zooted dude
he's per he's off the perk he's off the
gummy on this look at this he says bro
he goes there are Cathedrals everywhere
for those with eyes to see and he shows
a picture of a Avian water bottle it's
so [__] good
making me obsess like this is mushroom
posting not benzo dude this is way this
is psychosis brother yeah I love that
I've been there I've been there buddy
yeah is that water bottle for four hours
look at that it's a little Cathedral
like what yeah
I watched this
shadow of the avian bottle I heard the
chanting inside the cathedral maybe I
cried it was beautiful maybe he got
apple cider again in his diet or
something oh no
oh no bro hmm
there was a service inside they were
saving the souls of trans women I was
sitting on the bus that day I started
crying I couldn't stop crying I missed
my stop
I rode and rode all day
staring at the Cathedral hearing the
church bells ring bing bong
bing bong
bing bong the tall it it tools for me
I saw myself in the mirror with my dick
tucked between my legs
I said am I the mangina
who's the mangina I said then my
grandmother's pubes in a paintbrush
brushed upon my face I was back in the
cathedral
the pope spit on my face I told him he's
a coward I told the pope he's woke but
she did do that he did yeah you're too
woke and gay Mr Pope River
Region was exposed oh God cut it off
Jesus I heard myself talking about my
maternal grandmother oh no her pubes
grabbed on the floor like a long
she walks circles around me as her long
pubes had Bells tied to it and made
slight Jingles like cows coming back
from the pasture
foreign
I grabbed onto her pubic robe and she
slid me across the ground okay God
it's so horrible
her labia started to
stretchy
badge of honor it's two two I started
crawling up an attempt to crawl back
inside of her where I was safe [__] you
and warm I don't like it
all right we only have like what we're
talking about is still more
comprehensible than like Jordan
Peterson's Looney Tunes uh that's true
okay like even what you just did right
there makes more sense than the [__]
Looney Tunes reference that he keeps
using apparently no doubt I want some
apologies for that I actually can't go
this is actually two faces outfit like
actually yeah he just tries to Vice
signaling baby he's trying to look like
a villain that's it like we looked to a
villainous the closer we look to
villains that you see the archetypical
villain the better we are and the more
money we get from the oil Lobby
right I just don't care that's the point
in fact my Nazi flares in the in the
mail and I wear it not because I'm a
Nazi but just to show you how little I
care we know what happens when the right
goes too far which is kind of good
really but do we know what happens when
the left goes too far right God forbid
we get health care for all Americans
they've gone too far this something I
enjoy in Canada schools lunches my God
man where does it end
yeah
it's insane we need to call CPS and
round up these children
it's it's oh God
oh okay we're running out of time let's
do the Joe Rogan yeah one one segue off
of this is that you know thank God
Jordan Peterson's keeping comedy live
but you know what who else is keeping
comedy alive Ethan me no not you uh
thankfully with the button we're we're
limiting your comedy a little bit but uh
if you want to say unhin [__] there is a
place you can go to Ethan that's right
finally finally who will shake comedy to
The Next Step who will defend comedy
that's right I'm of course talking about
Joseph Robinette Rogan Joe Rogan
[Applause]
by the way this is um it doesn't really
have the same middle name as
no I I always say that is it I like it I
like without
um getting into the drug and do
psychosis the Jordan Peterson is
experiencing this I wanted to just get
you as close as possible bro this is
literally what would happen in America
like if sponsor you know what I mean
Beyond or whatever how are you saying
yeah
Joe Rogan has opened his anti-cancel
Culture Club in Austin that is how he's
billing it yeah in the comedy Mothership
that's the name of the club and he's
he's selling it like the the selling
point of it is that it is an anti-cancel
culture Comedy Club hell yeah finally
finally dude because finally you know
normally all the [__] comedy clubs
I've gone to in in my entire life
they're always just so woke they're
always talking about the woke of [__] in
there you know I mean yeah I mean every
when's the last time you saw a prominent
stand-up comedian that didn't name their
special like canceled dude I I saw Dave
Chappelle I think that was the last
person I saw live recently uh not
recently like uh maybe like a year ago
that was the last person I saw live
testing out his new bits in the
immediate aftermath of like uh putting
out a special and that's usually the
where comedians are their weakest right
because like they have to come up with
new material the only way to figure out
new material is by you know figuring out
what gets you laughed sure right and the
entire time is just blasting [__]
lung darts on stage in in the uh in the
uh the small room upstairs at The Comedy
Store my favorite uh Comedy Club
um in Los Angeles
and he was he was literally the room was
[__] packed he smoking cigarettes
constantly just chirping about little
like trans kids and how annoyed he is
that like they yell at him so it was
basically a TED Talk it was it was just
a TED talk but like uh you know an
anti-woke Ted talk so if that's what's
gonna happen at The Joe Rogan Comedy
Mothership you know I'm at will I'm not
interested well so here is well what I
found interesting first of all it's a 40
um
cover cover which is that's pretty high
just to cruise in isn't it for comedy
club I'd say yeah they also have huge
opening acts like Roseanne Barr
Roseanne Barr yes they're having her in
there and pretending like and Ron white
dude what are you doing like Tim Dylan I
get you know what I mean uh you know
shouts out to Tim Dylan but you got
Roseanne Barr Ron White and Tony
Hinchcliffe who's like you know Tony
henchman of Joe Rogan uh he's like kind
of mid I guess you know he has the
audience still possibly and then Dave
Chappelle is the closer God that is the
most
I mean that lineup Tim can't say this
because you know or or most comedians
can't say this because they want to uh
perform at the comedy Mothership and I
really want this place to be good I do
but that lineup is not as stacked as you
would uh want it to be
what do you think about the fact that
Joe Rogan scans people's faces to enter
I find that odd wait really he has face
scanners that and uh
that people have to submit to to enter
the [__] Comedy Club
okay anti Joe Rogan the venue's theme is
aliens meets Art Deco the latter a
respectful not to the remodel theater's
century-long history there is a UFO
above the door in the lobby warnings
that hecklers will be alienated in a
stargate-like arch over the main stage
love all that stuff that stuff is cute
I'm a fan of all that you know it's nice
and I know Joe Rogan cares about comedy
deep down inside even if it's like even
if his own personal comedy is not that
great I know he cares about this [__]
right
um and I think that this could be
possibly cool I don't know I haven't
seen the video bro that line is whack
that is not impressive well regardless
the venue's theme is is you know it's
it's whatever it's it's not that big
it's not it's not that big of a deal
it's whatever
um but the logistics of the uh matter
that you were talking about uh he's
helped uh lead Rogan has helped lead the
practice of banning phones and comedy
shows which I agree with by the way I
think that's a good thing I'm 100 in
support of that uh Dave Chappelle does
it uh as well you have those like little
Faraday cage style boxes that you put
your phone into as a sleeve that gets a
magnetic lock placed on it I think it's
uh it's smart it's understandable it's
one way to try and and get ahead of
people like filming your test bits you
know what I mean and I I don't have an
issue with that
um
but uh security is a bit intense as you
have to get your face scanned like
you're going through the airport
security at Heathrow that seems a little
while what do you think about the face
scanning that really threw me off
why are we scanning faces
like genuinely why are we doing that I
don't know uh it's rumor to help
identify hecklers and identify people
using fake IDs I guess that's what
they're saying there's like famous
hecklers don't let him in
he's a Heckler from what I could
research I think it's a thing that like
higher end newer clubs are doing like
not necessarily like comedy clubs but
like nightclubs they have like a no-fly
list uh it might be for that I don't
know
some people in the chat saying it's
common at nightclubs now so yeah I think
I mean I agree just because it just
seems like something Joe Rogan would be
like worried about like dystopian and
[__] but also like his all of Joe Rogan
like pretending like he hates big Tech I
mean the dude is friends with [__]
Elon Musk is like he doesn't really have
an aversion to all that stuff so I don't
know here actually is the real when the
real comedian takes stage this is the
button-free Zone I like to call it
thank you
The button-free Zone that's what my
comedy special will be called it's
another way to say you can't cancel
remember though like when they see their
anti-cancel culture or when they say
they're like uh you know Pro uh comedy
they mean like Pro whatever their
perspective is because if you were
actually Pro comedy and and you had
access to Dave Chappelle you would
literally sit him down and be like bro
you are literally just doing a
transphobic Ted talk now that's all you
do please go back to the good [__] what
are you doing what are you doing because
all he does is [__] complain like an
old out of touch guy who is very rich
people love it though no no but they
don't they they do this this is very
different the conservatives love it this
is very different than haha this okay if
you're if you're going for a plot he
thinks he's doing George Carlin but like
a hateful bigot version of George Carlin
yeah but God it just sucks it sucks so
bad it does but George Carlin was also
funny on top of like punching up or
whatever there was also an element of
humor because it it you know perfectly
broke down societal constructs that were
ridiculous and laughable and laughed at
it right
just simply stating for the 17 18th time
that like trans people are kind of weird
huh what's going on with that it's like
a man wearing a dress it's like oh okay
hey do you think um they let me in the
club wearing my John Brown hoodie
um probably I mean open Perry it depends
on how it depends on how far carry with
my John Brown hoodie
that make you uncomfortable
it depends on how far gone they are from
you know
um because a lot of those guys get like
really really upset when you are
doing the same kind of humor but on the
left
that's it
that's it that's about the show eh it's
about the show and I think we
successfully made it without the audio
getting all [__] up this week
for last week everybody
anything else passing
no that that's it that's all I got too I
I don't have anything else no notes
nice bro good episode today I think so
we got him we got him I think so we we
saved comedy a little bit we should
start our own comedy club called
woke comedy only
that sounds great where no offensive
jokes are ever allowed yeah the Nanette
I was about to say we just it's it's her
every night yeah Hannah Gatsby only it's
only Hannah gads being like [__] you
know Tech crunch like VC startup guys
who get up there and talk about like
sustainable uh disruptive Technologies
or whatever the [__] that sounds
hilarious hey did you guys hear the one
about the lab-grown meat
it was delicious it's delicious and it's
reducing carbon emissions that's right
we're working on lowering the price so
it was actually competitive with real
meat we should get we should ban
hamburgers no hamburgers in this club no
laughs allowed actually you can't even
laugh don't laugh too loud please we do
this it's considered heck we do the snap
thing please snapping only you're
disturbing laughter is decadence sir
okay this is me and you oh wow that's
powerful
Cathedral Ethan
Ethan I'm looking down I'm looking down
at all the Believers that are walking
through the doors of Evian Cathedral
sponsored by Evian
I looked up at what the tears went down
my face the two beautiful Avion Towers
looked like my grandmother's breasts
okay they were obviously way more perky
and Pokey my grandmothers went down to
her knees I used to droop on them like a
swing over ravine
I would put I would take hurdled rope
like pubes and wrap it around my waist
and I would hold on to her droopy
swingers and swing all the Dale away
those were the best days of my life
Zack start the start the theme music
please
and that's where I thank you so much
wish I could be let's pull the camera
out Bring it on them droopers yeah
let's do the let's talk
[Music]
thank you